PETE LEPAGE: Hi, I'm Pete, a
developer advocate at Google.
We all know that a
snappy website is always
a great thing.
It means happier users
and higher conversions.
And fast is especially
important on mobile,
where everybody is
always in a hurry.
PageSpeed Insights
is an awesome tool
that you can use to improve
the performance of your site.
When you profile a page
with PageSpeed Insights,
it evaluates the
page and gives you
a score based on performance
and user experience,
based on a set of criteria
and best practices.
For a quick, easy
analysis, you can just
hit the PageSpeed
Insights service
by clicking the link on screen.
But let's give the
Web Fundamentals site
a try to see how it works.
I'll enter a URL and
hit the Analyze button.
After a few seconds, PageSpeed
reports back its findings.
On this page, we scored a
70 out of 100 for speed.
Not bad, but there's certainly
room for improvement here.
It gives us a list of
criteria that we should fix.
On this page, it recommends
that we eliminate
the render-blocking
CSS and scripts.
In our case, it's
our primary CSS file
and a CSS file that loads
some specialized fonts.
It also tells us that we should
check the caching headers
on some of our files.
It looks like a
couple of the files
are cached for 60 minutes.
And we definitely want
to up that number.
We had eight rules pass,
there are no redirects,
and the page weight
has been optimized
by turning on compression and
minifying the JavaScript, HTML,
CSS, and images.
The above-the-fold content
has been properly prioritized
and the servers are
responding quickly.
Perfect, we're in
a good situation.
Now, we get a similar report
for the user experience rules.
It looks like this page was
dinged two points because some
of the tap targets are a
little bit too close together.
Otherwise, the page is good.
It doesn't use any
plug-ins, the viewport
is configured properly, and
the content is sized to fit,
and all the font sizes
are large enough to read.
This is great as a
manual, one-off analysis,
but you can go even deeper.
You can integrate
PageSpeed Insights directly
into your development workflow
with the PageSpeed Insights
API.
It uses a simple REST API
that takes three parameters:
the URL that we want to test,
the API key that identifies
our project-- and,
oh, by the way,
that-- not really my API key,
so don't bother trying it--
and the strategy,
either desktop or mobile
that you want to test against.
You can learn about some of
the other optional parameters
in the documentation.
Now, if you don't
already have an API key,
you'll need to enable
the PageSpeed Insights
API in the Google
Developer Console.
And you can get your key there.
The PageSpeed Insights
API returns its result
as a JSONObject.
It includes the server
response code, the final URL,
and the score.
It also includes page stats
such as the total number
of each resource downloaded,
the total number of hosts,
and the size of the request.
And finally, the results
of all the rules tested.
Each PageSpeed rule
generates an impact number
that indicates the importance
or priority of implementing
that set of suggestions
for the rule
relative to the other rules.
For instance, if
enabling compression
would save one megabyte, while
optimizing images would save
500k, then the enable
compression rule
would have an
impact value that's
twice that of the
optimized images rule.
You can query the URL
from the command line,
or better yet, just automate it.
Grunt makes the command
line testing super easy.
The Grunt PageSpeed
plug-in simply
tests the deployed pages,
reporting the PageSpeed score,
page stats, and the
individual rule results.
If the PageSpeed score falls
below the specified threshold,
well, then the Grunt task fails.
By testing your site
regularly with a Cron job
or other scheduled task
and saving the results,
you can use PageSpeed Insights
to track your site over time.
Small changes, when
looked at individually,
may not make a big difference,
but over time, these numbers
add up, helping you
to spot regressions
or see trends that you
might otherwise have missed.
By adding PageSpeed Insights
to your development workflow
today, you can ensure that your
pages follow the best practices
for performance and
user experiences.
And you can spot trends
before they become a problem.
So go, test your
pages right now,
and then add PageSpeed
Insights to your workflow.
Thanks for watching, and
go build something awesome.